[Music]
but part of I won't see you is unclear I
respected your wishes for a weak heart
we've got bigger concerns we don't have
any concerns how yes we do I'm hosting a
summit with sky crew at sundown will
they return to your people like all that
trouble to capture me just to let me go
I went to all that trouble to save you
you know what I could have used saving
when you abandoned me at Mount weather
clearly you didn't need my help
clearly you're angry Clark but I know
you what you've done haunts you that's
easier to hate me than today yourself oh
I can do pop what would you have done if
their leader and offered you the deal
save your people at the price of mine
would you really have chosen differently
I don't betray my friends but you did
you had friends in that weather those
deaths are on YouTube the only
difference is you have no honor and I
had no choice
it helps no one to dwell on the past and
that's not why I'm here
you're right I'm not just letting you go
back to your people I want something
more I want your people to become my
people I'm offering sky crew the chance
to join my coalition become the 13th
clan
no one would dare to move against you
because that would be moving against me
leave me alone I'm done do you
understand that
I left you can't run away from who you
are Clarke
join me now before me and your people
will be safe bow before you you don't
give a damn about my people I know why
you're here I made you look weak at
Mount weather
and now the ice nation is exploiting
that well if you want the power of one
Hannah
kill me take it
otherwise no flow or some because I'm
never
the hundred all new this Thursday at 9/8
central on the CW